Протистоїмо коронавірусу, як можемо та  як вважаємо за необхідне.
В нас на ринку краще, ніж скрізь! Ми де не були..  Київ - ніхто маски не носить.
Це один з ринків на Київщині  - в Кагарлику. І тут фактично немає жодного продавця,
який би не ізолював себе від покупців ось такими конструкціями з плівки.
Захист від коронавірусу! Щоб не було прямого спілкування між собою!
Санітарна самодисципліна деяких продавців вражає.
Наталія дуже ретельно слідкує, щоб в неї не було прямого контакту ні з ким і ні з чим ззовні.
Навіть гроші дезінфікує.
Так, пирскаємо!  І хазяйці в кульок складаю і далі віддаю.
Копійки  так само попирскаю.  От така житуха в нас!
Деякі покупці теж інакше не можуть.
Ручки обробляємо і поїхали додому. Приїхали додому -помили руки  і знов обробили.
Продавці кажуть, що готові виконувати будь-які санітарні правила,
аби тільки мати можливість працювати,
і інколи навіть примушують покупців їх дотримуватися.
Овочів та фруктів , стверджують, торкатися не дають.
Якщо сильно хочуть,  то є рукавчики  одноразові! Якщо дуже хочуть. А так ми не дозволяємо!
На практиці, звичайно, так не завжди. Ідеально санітарні правила виконують одиниці.
Особливо щодо захисних масок та способу їх носіння. На підборідді, під носом.
Діти взагалі переважно без масок. А інколи і дорослі.
У мене горло болить.
Немає. Зараз йду, купляю  ось там, за кутом!
Не боїтеся?  Боїмося!
Подружжя Бурденків завітало в гості до Кагарлика з Німеччини.
Олександр і Олена зізнаються, що перед поїздкою в Україну дуже переймалися про свою безпеку.
Сумнівалися, що  українці виконуватимуть правила так само дисципліновано, як німці.
Ми приємно вражені, що усі носять маски. Бережуть себе та інших.
Коли перетинали кордон, - в Борисполі, ми помітили, що іноземці всі тримаються на відстані,
а українці гуртуються і на це не звертають уваги..
Якщо ось так маски стирчать, ми просимо, щоб одягли.
В Кагарлику і Кагарлицькому районі за весь період епідемії
були зафіксовані одиниці хворих на коронавірус.
Район поки тримається в "зеленій зоні". Утім, за даними облдержадміністрації,
останніми днями на Київщині різко збільшився рівень захворюваності
і навіть є антирекорд  з кількості померлих.
В Кагарлику ще навесні готувалися до найгіршого сценарію.
Якщо в Кагарлику раптом з’явиться велика кількість людей з підозрою на коронавірус,
то цей намет МНС  стане місцем для проведення первинного медичного огляду.
Після чого людей  будуть відправляти вже в спеціалізовані  лікарні.
Кагарлицьку району лікарню ще навесні перепрофілювали в опорну
- для прийому хворих на коронавірус не лише з Кагарлика і району, а й з інших районів Київщини.
Останні два тижні кількість хворих дещо збільшилася,
але  не настільки, щоб ми не справлялися.
Кагарлицьких фактично немає, більшість з області.  Багато Вишневе , Васильків
Дуже багато Обухівський район. Райони, які прилеглі до Києва.
Це  спеціалізоване інфекційне відділення лікарні. Його побудували 30 років тому таким чином,
щоб лікарі мали можливість заходити до пацієнтів з вулиці: кожен бокс має окремий вхід.
Це спеціалізоване  інфекційне відділення, по ГОСТах та стандартах побудоване.
В нас, як немає коронавірусу, то в нас лікували і кір, і вітрянку
Щоб не було внутрішньолікарняної інфекції,  ми заклеїмо внутрішні двері, ходимо до хворих з вулиці.
Завідувачку відділенням Людмилу Дзененко часто викликають  на роботу і в вихідні.
Наразі тут перебуває майже 35 пацієнтів з підозрою на коронавірус  і з підтвердженим діагнозом.
Я зараз йду оглядати хворого з підтвердженим ковідом , який щойно поступив у відділення.
Скорочуємо до мінімуму  час перебування  у хворого.
Лікарі-інфекціоністи наразі працюють майже в турборежимі.  Проте, на відміну від нардепів,
роблять свою роботу не лише швидко, а й дуже ретельно. Адже у випадку з коронавірусом
захисний одяг не мусить заважати оцінити, наскільки критичний стан хворого,
навіть якщо на перший погляд у пацієнта все добре.
У березні, розповідає лікарка, траплялося, що стан пацієнта погіршувався настільки швидко і раптово,
що втрятувати людину не вдавалося. Усього за період епідемії в реанімації лікарні
померли 11 осіб. Зараз це поодинокі випадки і майже завжди через супутні хвороби.
По-перше, літо.  Все-таки вірулентність вірусу послаблена, ультрафіолетові проміні зменшують.
Інший момент те, що по троху колективний імунітет з’являється.
Немає такого агресивного перебігу, який був, скажімо, в квітні.
Лікарка розповідає, що за півроку епідемії вона з колегам вже навчилася поєднувати різні препарати,
аби  стабілізувати фізичний стан хворих. В лікарні запевняють,  що значно покращилася
і ситуація з ліками, обладнанням, киснем. Навіть закупили кисневі концентратори,
апарати ШВЛ високого класу.
На сьогодні в нас немає проблем ніяких.
Якщо буде в такому темпі, в нас  запас медикаментів і засобів захисту десь  на 2 місяці
Якщо збільшення, ми замовляємо. В нас  підписаний пакет на ковід с НЗСУ.
І вони нас забезпечують коштами в достатній кількості .
За даними благодійного фонду "Пацієнти України ", 70% лікарень в усіх регіонах
в середньому забезпечені ліками та захисним одягом для лікарів максимум на місяць-два.
Проте,  якщо коронавірусна статистика і далі буде на антирекордному рівні, лікарням загрожуватиме колапс,
оскільки план тендерних закупівель для лікарень до кінця року ще не допрацьований на рівні уряду.
Саме зараз, кажуть лікарі, з початком навчання у школах, після повернення усіх з відпусток,
може розпочатися гостра фаза другої хвилі епідемії. Треба бути максимально обережним.
Натомість на вулицях українських міст  з’являється дедалі більше людей взагалі без масок.
Як от тут на стихійному ринку в Кагарлику.
Ось дивіться, проходить піт в окулярах, я надягаю. Я ж дихаю сюди, мені нічого не видно!
Цей вісімдесятип'ятирічний дідусь показує при цьому руки,
які блищать від антисептиків, і висловлює свою думку про другу хвилю епідемії.
Та ну ії …Не боюся, ніхто мене не заразить.
А чого  мені заразять?! Я той рік перехворів на таке. 2 тижні був,  видро крапельниць влили.
Він мене не візьме, мені так сказали лікарі.
Насправді вже є дані про те, що повторне зараження COVID-19 не виключене. Крім того,
навіть одужавши від коронавірусу, людина може як наслідок мати потім проблеми зі здоров'ям.
Двобічні пневмонії, от ці тяжкі, то відбуваються фіброзні зміни.
І як це в подальшому відобразиться на здоров'ї людини, ми передбачити не можемо.
Попри втому від тих же масок та постійного страху захворіти,  треба, наголошує лікарка-інфекціоністка,
взяти на себе відповідальність за своє здоров’я і робити все можливе, аби уникнути зараження.
Дистанція в два метри, маска  - точно не на підборідді, регулярне миття рук.
І ще - транспортом, де сидять люди без масок, краще не користуватися.